foreign
now allow me to just share a couple of
scams that a lot of people don't know
about that are happening all over the
world all right so everybody right now
pull out your phone text your mom text
your dad be like hey do you have a
financial advisor out of curiosity and
they'll be like oh yeah we use chat
chat's so nice Chet's been with our
family for 34. I'm like shuts a
scammer I'd love to show you how to find
out so you go oh out of curiosity um how
much does Chet charge you and Mom and
Dad can be like oh um I don't know you
know we it's in the prospectus some of
that document somewhere you know just
pull out that thing screenshot it for me
take a look take a look
most times it's going to be a percentage
okay and it's going to be something like
one percent and this is where I start to
get pissed because one percent doesn't
sound like that much oh one percent
that's fine somebody's paying attention
to my money they're keeping an eye on my
portfolio I really just like I have
somebody to do my gardening I have a
financial let me explain the
math one percent over the course of your
lifetime means you will pay
approximately 28 of your returns to this
advisor oh wow if you are paying two
percent
you're paying over 50 of your returns
directly to that advisor do you realize
how ridiculous that is wow for example
if somebody comes and washes your car do
you pay them a percentage of your net
worth no you pay 20 bucks 50 bucks even
200 bucks but never a percentage so your
parents if they use somebody like Chet a
commission based financial advisor they
are losing thousands hundreds of
thousands over the course of their
lifetime now do am I saying all
financial advisors are bad no
there are times you can use a financial
advisor I've even hired one myself I
hired one specifically because I had a
specific project I was like take a look
at my asset allocation I want a second
set of eyes they charge me a few hundred
bucks an hour I was happy to pay it
great
if you choose to use a financial advisor
which the majority of people do not need
never pay a percentage-based fee it's
called AUM assets under management pay
an hourly fee pay a project fee but do
not pay a percentage fee all right so
that's the number one thing that's
happening that people don't even realize
I feel so sorry for your parents but
paste the chat responses in the chat
below because I want to see what they
say you're about to find out you know Ma
Ma and Pa have been getting uh taken to
the cleaners for about 25 years there
are a bunch of other scams High expense
ratios uh active investing we can talk
about all that but that's one that I am
on a crusade to end I want you to take
control of your money and if you decide
you need help after reading a book my
book other books what watching my show
you can get an advisor but never pay a
percentage-based fee yeah man my uh one
experience with an advisor is when I
started to go to college and I started
like 23 24. um because work was paying
for it but long story short you know you
got to fill out the FAFSA stuff and then
they send you these checks and they
don't even ask you if you want the
checks they're just like here's a check
for like five grand here's a check for
12 Grand and some of them are subsidized
and some of them are unsums unsubsidized
so the subsidized you have time before
it starts to collect interest so I got
like a five thousand dollar subsidized
check and I was like oh I wonder if I
can invest this over the next four years
or five years and maybe make a little
bit of money on it and then pay it off
before it starts to collect interest
okay and this was in yeah it was around
2008 like two that I love it yeah
fantastic yeah and uh that go oh yeah so
uh I didn't end up doing it because
something just like
rubbed me the wrong way I must have it
must have been earlier 2007. it just
read me the wrong way with the finance
guy I was like this this doesn't oh you
talk to a guy I went in and I'm like I
got four grand here's what I want to do
do you want to say the company that you
went into I don't uh I don't exercise
it's probably the only one anyone ever
thinks of anyway
yeah that's right you know exactly what
I'm talking about but no I went in there
and yeah I like it just read me the
wrong way because there was no he I was
really looking for someone to help me to
understand the risk you never once under
help me understand the risk of it he was
just it was like all upside Give Me Your
Money salesman yeah and I walked out of
there and I returned that check and then
yeah the crash happened I was like oh
I'm really glad I didn't do that he
never he never mentioned that this could
happen
you would never by the way you would
never borrow money to invest money in
the stock market yeah you wouldn't go to
the bank and say hey I need a loan for
four thousand five thousand dollars what
are you gonna do with it um well I just
want to buy some individual stocks or
maybe put the S P 500 you would never do
that no no so underneath that story
which really enrages me because why on
Earth are they taking college kids money
and all there's so many things that are
wrong with that but I I want to
highlight a couple things I want
everybody to know first off you know
there's this phrase timing the market
right what is timing the market and
that's
individual people any of us or even
professionals on Wall Street saying
don't invest right now because it's not
a good time or the economy is going back
don't do that okay timing the market
will almost certainly result in you
losing money yeah this is very hard to
believe I cover the research in the book
but in general even the fanciest Wall
Street investors failed to beat the
market like basically that means they
fail to beat a low-cost Index Fund which
you and I can buy right now 80 of the
time
don't try to guess if the Market's going
up or down you have no idea I have no
idea nobody has any idea instead you
just set up your accounts to
automatically invest every single month
just take yourself out of the equation
doesn't matter what's in the news
doesn't matter what's going on anywhere
every single month on the exact same day
your account is going to automatically
invest 50 bucks 500 bucks 5 000 bucks
and overtime research shows that is the
most effective way versus trying to time
the market yeah yeah in fact whenever I
hear like oh it's it's time to to sell
it don't buy like what I hear is like oh
like the stock market's on sale right
now like it's okay it's like yeah just
keep putting some a little bit in yeah
yeah what are some of these other scams
that you wanted to talk about um right
now the biggest scam going around tick
tock is uh whole life insurance
yeah so this is what they do they you
get some guy in an ill-fitting uh like
under armor shirt okay always wearing
shorts and I'm like first of all I'm not
taking Financial advice from a guy
wearing Under Armor get the out of
here and second of all he he's like
eating lunch I everyone watching this
knows exactly who I'm talking about
they're like eating lunch in their like
office cafeteria and and someone comes
in like and they go hey uh I really want
to invest a bunch of money but I'm not
sure what to do what should I do he goes
let me show you and he walks over to the
Whiteboard he goes all right let me
break it down if you're investing in a
401k you're losing money Roth IRA that's
for losers here's what you do you borrow
against the money you invest it the
whole the whole life insurance company
pays you this and it's free money I go
I'm gonna kill you right now
it's it's like watching a car dealer
scam somebody in real time
selling it's
a god this is free money and then I look
in the comments there's like 8 000 Tick
Tock people going
um interested interested interested and
I'm like you guys are doomed like I I
truly wish so
let me let me explain very simply that
in personal finance
you want to passively invest which means
you do not want to be picking individual
stocks and you do not want the middlemen
as much as possible you want to
eliminate middlemen what that means is
if an insurance first of all insurance
is insurance it's not investment so do
not treat Insurance like an investment
yeah and they go well well it's it can
work for wealthy people I go first of
all I know you're not wealthy and second
of all I'm wealthy and I know what you
get out of that and I'm not investing in
that horse so even as you get to
the higher levels of personal finance
the fundamentals are the same just like
uh NBA players still practices they're
same practices they did in the early
days they're practicing dribbling
I'm doing passive investing low-cost
index funds keep it simple that's all
you got to do and stay away from whole
life insurance please
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free